well I was a joke that bad
I'm gonna kill you
[Applause]
what I think my catch that you're gonna
have to speak up not today not tomorrow
but I'm gonna kill you
Simon what do you have knife
yeah hatchet and Max Simon is about
right-hand man haven't one of those is
important I mean what do you have left
without him a whole lot of work you have
one maybe one of these fine people still
breathing
or did I
sure yeah give me his axe
be right back baby bricks will be with
me
if not well we can just turn these
people inside out won't we
I mean the ones that are left
hey youtubers is Charlie so if you're
wondering why everyone's freaking out
about this Walking Dead footage its from
episode one which is in two weeks but
it's a big deep cut from the governor
comics so just careful for spoilers from
like the really early governor comics
and The Walking Dead so here we go
most of you even if you haven't read the
comics probably know what's going on in
this he's making all these right-hand
jokes and you know what happened to Rick
Grimes in the comics but that was during
the governor's reign so they're kind of
doing an homage to the governor during
issue 28 of the comic book with this
negan scene here so everyone's like wait
a minute are they gonna cut Rick's hand
off like they said they were never gonna
do that they said it was too difficult
they said it'd be too expensive to do
the special effects but then people are
like well they did Hershel they cut
Herschel's leg off so all the way up to
the top with even like Robert Kirkman
going back years haven't you know
they've been flip-flopping on whether or
not something like that was even
possible
but the thing about that though is is
that you can't really bank on what
someone says a couple years ago because
think about how they started off doing
the show and it was almost nothing like
the comics like they had a couple of
comic book moments cut a couple years
later all the way through season 5 6 & 7
and we've actually been following the
comics pretty closely albeit with a
slightly different roster like they had
some characters that weren't in the
comics like Daryl's not in the comics so
they use certain characters in slightly
different ways but when people get
killed they still do big comic book
kills even if the character is a little
bit different so they have big comic
book moments they're opening the season
with the rest of that negan kill they've
been teasing that even more than one
person might get killed and this is them
just teasing hey look this is only the
beginning we might do the thing that you
never thought that we would do which i
think is the challenge for The Walking
Dead now like show us something that
isn't possible
you've been six years of the
ultraviolent you've done some big comic
book moments now surprised us by doing
the thing that you said you were never
going to do so just to explain the way
it happened in the comics this is issue
28 so this is like way early on just to
give you an idea of how far we are from
governor stuff in the comics so the
governor like the big Rick
governor hand moment is an issue 28
negan doesn't even appear in the comics
till issue 100 so we're blowing past
that right here I wouldn't be surprised
if we get to all-out war by the end of
this season but they might even move
that up too so you don't necessarily
have to read along in the comics but if
you really like to do that it's a lot of
fun so just to explain that issue 28
what happens is is the governor is
seizing power he has them at his mercy
the same way negan has the survivors
here at his mercy and says you don't
understand the seriousness of the
situation to Rick
Rick's like I'm gonna kill you in boom
chops his hand right off so Rick wakes
up in a hospital realizes he only has
one hand but even though there's a lot
of governor dialogue that's transposed
onto negan here that doesn't necessarily
mean they'll cut his hand off but I do
think that it's gonna get way worse
before it gets better
that's kind of the way the Walking Dead
works like it takes you to the cliff
like at the end of last season this pool
of bloody gravel is actually the remains
of the person that negan killed or at
least one of the people that negan
killed if there is gonna be more than
one person but then when they open each
new season they start out with kind of
like the continuation of that like just
to like kick the energy off like oh my
god we're still in the middle of it and
then once that moment is over you're
like okay maybe we'll get a little bit
of rest but then they just jam on the
gas and it gets crazy again so I think
that's what they're trying to do with
Season seven because the audience has
been in decline just like a little bit
for the last couple of seasons the
Walking Dead is still one of the most
watched shows so the challenge this
season isn't showing you that there's
still so much left to do that's gonna be
really exciting that was the whole point
of Robert Kirkman introducing negan in
the comics because they gotten to issue
100 and people are like okay this has
been cool but it's not quite as exciting
anymore
and you know Robert Kirkman and Charlie
Adler like wait wait wait you know we
have all this awesome stuff that's
coming so BAM negan drops and gets
crazy so that's kind of what they're
trying to do with the TV show let me
know in the comments though do you think
that they will actually cut Rick's hand
off I think they can do it like it's a
lot easier to do Carl losing the eye
because he only has to walk around with
an eyepatch on it doesn't require a lot
of special effects but they explain
that doing Rick's hand would require
them doing a lot of blue and
green-screen so they have to shoot it in
strange ways even Robert Kirkman was
like how is he gonna reload his gun but
here they say he has a hatchet so there
are a couple ways to cheat it but just
remains to be seen if they actually have
the balls to go there so everybody give
them a hand
make all the hand jokes he could think
of because two weeks episode 1 dropping
I'll be doing videos all season so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
the big thing this next week is that we
have like the four nights of the CW
superhero shows but I'll talk about that
during those videos so Walking Dead and
Walking Dead videos superhero comic book
stuff in the other comic book videos
although technically you know Walking
Dead is a comic book the tone is so
different from everything else that
sometimes you forget that it's a comic
book
forget hype it's gonna be awesome I
think this first half of the season is
gonna be really strong but these first
couple of episodes will give you an idea
for what the pace is gonna be like I
think they're definitely picking things
up I think that's the whole idea with
negan what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for like the
full Jon Bernthal Punisher panel he
talks a little bit about Walking Dead
stuff and you can click here for that
iron fist trailer again thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow